[Musique]
alors après cette date de cette longue
période de confinement nous sommes très
heureux évidemment de vous retrouver au
ciné 7 et notamment avec le coup de
coeur du ciné cette semaine une sortie
nationale
c'est un petit peu difficile en ce
moment parce que les distributeurs sont
relativement frileux mais on est très
content de sortir le second film 2
grégory magne
le réalisateur qui avait précédemment
réalisé le film l'air de rien avec
michel delpech qui racontait les affres
d'un chanteur un peu esseulé et oublié
et cette fois ci le film qui s'appelle
les parfums il est interprétée par
emmanuelle devos que tout le monde
connaît qu'un la ville homo cas
récemment avec isabelle huppert et un
autre acteur qui s'appelle grégory
moutel voilà qui avait déjà joué dans
l'air de rien donc les parfums c'est
l'histoire d'une parfumeuse enfin de
quelqu'un qui crée des frags ans qui est
quelqu'un de un petit peu hautain
supérieur qui vit isolé dans son monde
elle est très connue très réputé et elle
va recruter un jour un chauffeur qui ne
va pas avoir peur de s'opposer à elle et
il va se tisser forcément des liens
relativement intéressant entre les deux
le servage pas un seul instant vous avez
le lever la tête pour la regarder les
gens pas qu'une odeur si vous n'êtes
même pas capable de lire de mots juste
deux mots merci saint pry
pour de bon
voilà c'est l'histoire de ce film que
vous pourrez découvrir cette semaine sur
nos écrans au ciné c'est très ouvert
d'elancourt
[Musique]